[Music]
as you guys know i host my own show and
i'm also a writer for the show late
night with seth meyers and then
recently i thought to myself i'm not
busy enough
so i wrote a book i wrote it with my big
sister lacey
and it's called you'll never believe
what happened to lacey
crazy stories about racism now lacey
lives in omaha nebraska where we grew up
and people are always saying very crazy
racist things to her so
we wrote them all down and put them in
this book and
guess what lacey is here in the studio
tonight to talk about it welcome lacey
hello yay lacey is my first interview
guest and
i'm extremely excited that she is here
but i'm gonna act very chill about it
now lacey uh how did we come up with the
idea for this book
um so many racist things happened to me
and they've happened throughout my whole
life that we've always talked about
i need to start a book and start putting
all of these stories in there and it
just became this running joke something
would happen to me and you would be like
that's going into the book yes that's i
mean
it is crazy how
many stories lacey has about racist
stuff
but then if you cut out all of the
stories that aren't
absolutely hilarious you still have
this many stories um
these stories are absolutely insane uh
lacey what's your favorite one
um my favorite one is
i was having a meeting at work um there
was only one other
black woman that worked with me and i'm
having this meeting
i'm talking to this lady after the
meeting was over
she said and now can you ask lacie to
come in
and she was talking to me so i had to
let her know
i am lacey and we just sat there in
awkward silence for a moment
so did this lady look like you
absolutely not was she the same age as
you about
20 years younger did you have anything
in common no
no wait there you go
that's honest but actually that is the
wrong
answer the right answer is this story
this is my favorite story of the book
um lacey had uh checks
she had black history month checks black
history checks it's more than a month
i'm sorry
she had black history checks and uh you
know they'd have like
martin luther king on it and malcolm x
and stuff so
she um buys something with a check and
she gives her check to the cashier
the cashier picks up the check and goes
whoa
your checks have your picture on them i
didn't even know you could do that
and the person on the check is harriet
tubman
and that is my favorite story of the
book but those are just
two of 500 stories okay let's see what
we
wrote on this thing okay um why
we wrote this book from a crazy uh list
that you had of stories why did you have
this list of racist things that have
happened to you
um every black person knows that when
you're at work
and things are said to you racist things
are said to you you're accused of
something
you have to document that so this is all
um and not all of it but a lot of the
book was written from document
notes that i just kept from work and so
when amber said let's start this book
you know where the notes that you said
you had i just pulled out a huge
stack of these journals that i would
keep for work
y'all okay so imagine remember when you
were a kid and you had
um a big big big big big trapper keeper
so imagine
all of those notes from since from like
seventh grade that is the giant binder
she had
um but it doesn't matter if you have
that binder
of things if you wrote it all down
because you can go to hr and still get
your feelings hurt
that's that was another option for the
title of this book
go to hr and get your feelings heard the
lacie lamar story
okay now lacey you asked me some
questions do you have any questions over
there i think i do oh okay
so you normally work with comedy writers
what's one way that working with your
sister
who's different well she's bad and i
don't like her
no i mean we did a lot of work on mom
and dad's couch
she did so drinking and laughing
yeah it was a lot of drinking and
laughing which is a way it's exactly the
same as being up in here
[Music]
but we did have a lot of fun but it was
also like
severe shorthand because it was like do
you remember that
incident in the disneyland parking lot
yeah i remember
okay let's put that in do you remember
the jcpenney's
uh incident which one and then you know
write those out but like this book
really turned out to be
a lot of fun
like i was scared that people would read
this book and
be like this is too much of a bummer but
i think the stories we chose are so
unbelievable that it makes it fun
you make it fun i like it when bad
things happen to you
i know you do you have any more
questions
um how do you hope people will feel when
you're
when they're reading our book i hope
they feel
uh scared
that's how i feel um i i don't know i
hope they feel enlightened
i i hope they feel moved to action
that's what i hope
without they see that what they've done
or what their friends have done and they
go oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] is in this book and
i act like this all the time
and then they think twice and then they
behave better
or they um
are like oh all this stuff has happened
to me and now i feel a little comforted
i don't know what's your hope
um i hope that people that are behaving
this way
in the book stop doing that
like people that are at work that are
calling people
negro or you know yeah
i've been called omaha nebraska
that i mean you gotta read this book
you're never gonna believe it uh
so last question lacey please do an
impression of me when i was young oh
that's easy um
i'm amber i love my little ponies okay
that's enough
that's uncomfortably accurate i don't
care for this anymore wait wait don't go
anywhere
i have big news i have my own youtube
channel now
yay be sure to subscribe for a lot of
show clips and a lot of digital
exclusives
and a lot of this see you there
[Applause]
[Music]